de votre présence donc nous poursuivons
ce matin nos travaux de notre commission
d'enquête avec l'audition de Monsieur
Antoine Peillon qui est secrétaire
général à la planification écologique
Monsieur le Secrétaire général vous
occupez ce poste depuis sa création le 7
juillet 2022 auparavant vous étiez en
charge des questions d'énergie et
d'environnement auprès du Premier
ministre et vous étiez conseillé
environnement énergie et transports à
l'Elysée de 2017 à 2019 enfin vous êtes
ingénieur du corps des mines la création
du secrétariat général à la
planification écologique prend son
origine dans l'une des annonces de
campagne du candidat Emmanuel Macron de
renforcer la planification écologique
afin notamment d'atteindre les objectifs
de gains et énergétique et de réduction
des gaz à effet de serre
ces attributions décritent dans le
décret du 7 juillet 2022 comprennent
notamment la coordination de
l'élaboration des stratégies nationales
en matière de climat d'énergie de
biodiversité et d'économie circulaire en
s'assurant du respect des engagements
européens et internationaux de la France
le contrôle de la cohérence de
l'ensemble des politiques publiques avec
les stratégies mentionnées et enfin il
veille à la mise en oeuvre de ces
stratégies par l'ensemble des ministères
concernés et à leur déclinaison en plan
d'action toutefois le secrétariat
général à la planification écologique
n'est pas la seule instance de
coordination et planification en matière
d'écologie il existe également un Haut
commissariat au plan et un commissariat
général au développement durable
pour le sujet qui nous intéresse il y a
également un coordinateur
interministériel du plan de rénovation
énergétique des bâtiments monsieur Simon
Yvetot que nous avons d'ailleurs déjà
auditionné dans le cadre de notre
commission d'enquête la répartition des
missions et des attributions entre ces
différentes fonctions peut donc être
difficile à démêler ma première question
porte sur vos attributions quel est le
rôle exact du secrétariat général à la
planification écologique en matière de
coordination et de planification de la
politique de rénovation énergétique des
bâtiments comment vous répartissez vous
les missions avec le coordinateur
interministériel du plan de rénovation
énergétique des bâtiments avez-vous des
instances de concertation
sur le fond votre fonction présente une
dimension stratégique dans le contexte
de l'élaboration de la prochaine
programmation plus réelle de l'énergie
un document du secrétariat général à la
planification écologique publiée dans la
presse indique que l'atteinte des
objectifs européens d'émission de gaz à
effet de serre en 2030 c'est-à-dire une
diminution de 55% des émissions par
rapport à 1990 supposerait un effort
cumulé de 190 millions de tonnes de CO2
à cet horizon le secteur du logement
résidentiel devrait diminuer ses
émissions de 27 millions de tonnes de
CO2 dont 17 millions par le remplacement
des chaudières fioul et gaz et 10
millions par la rénovation et la
sobriété résidentielle
pouvez-vous détailler comment ces
chiffres ont été déterminés et quels
sont leurs implications sur la politique
de rénovation énergétique des logements
à l'heure actuelle les politiques de
rénovation énergétique ont surtout connu
un succès pour le premier aspect le
remplacement des chaudières le
dispositif de base de ma prime rénov qui
représente près de 2,5 milliards d'euros
en 2023 finance en grande majorité des
changements de système de chauffage or
l'installation d'une pompe à chaleur
sans avoir réalisé les travaux
d'isolation nécessaire peut avoir des
effets
contre-productifs en termes de gains
énergétique dès lors estimez-vous que
l'équilibre entre les mesures visant au
changement de système de chauffage et
celles privilégiant l'isolation des
bâtiments et Satis comment peut-on
l'améliorer voilà déjà mes quelques
premières questions mais avant de vous
laisser la parole pour répondre à ces
questions et pour un propos introductif
une quinzaine de minutes il me revient
de vous indiquer que cette audition est
diffusée en direct et en différé sur le
site internet du Sénat et qu'un
compte-rendu sera publié je dois
également vous rappeler qu'un faux
témoignage devant notre commission
d'enquête serait passible des peines
prévues aux articles 434 13
434-14
434-15 du code pénal qui peuvent aller
de trois ans à 7 ans d'emprisonnement et
de 45000 euros à 100000 euros d'amende
voilà donc je vous invite à prêter
serment de dire toute la vérité rien que
la vérité a levé la main droite et à
dire je le jure
je vous en remercie donc Monsieur le
Secrétaire général je vous laisse la
parole et ensuite notre rapporteur vous
posera un certain nombre de questions
ainsi que nos collègues qui sont membres
de la commission d'enquête merci c'est à
vous
merci de la présidence mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs merci pour cette
audition que je pense importante sur le
sujet de la rénovation des bâtiments en
général et des logements en particulier
est assez très structurantes dans notre
politique de baisse de nos émissions de
gaz à effet de serre permettant
peut-être juste de prendre un tout petit
pas de recul sur le sujet de la
planification écologique et ce que fait
le secrétariat général on a du coup
derrière le terme de planification
écologique on cherche à la fois à
traiter des sujets de baisse d'émission
de gaz à effet de serre mais aussi des
sujets d'adaptation au changement
climatique des sujets aussi relatifs à
la protection de la biodiversité à
l'économie de nos ressources durables
donc économie circulaire mais aussi les
préoccupations sur la disponibilité en
matière de lithium de cuivre de
matériaux qui sont stratégiques qui est
important pour notre souveraineté et
puis aussi des préoccupations de santé
environnement quand on parle de
pollution atmosphérique par exemple il y
a un homme de facteurs importants qui
sont liés à des enjeux environnementaux
et donc c'est 5 enjeux donc la bête des
émissions adaptation la biodiversité
l'économie circulaire et santé
environnement nous amène du coup avoir
une vision très transversale sur un très
grand nombre de politiques publiques en
matière bien sûr de logement et c'est le
cœur de la discussion aujourd'hui mais
aussi en matière en matière de transport
par exemple ou d'industrie ou encore de
d'agriculture ou de production d'énergie
donc les travaux que nous menons alors
ils sont lavés soulignés ce que tu as
général a été installé récemment et nous
sommes pour l'instant une petite équipe
puisque nous sommes en tout 15 personnes
nous avons du coup en train de renforcer
puisqu'il y a il y a 10 recrutements qui
qui sont en train d'être ouverts en
supplément mais donc du coup on
travaille aussi à hauteur de ces de ces
15 personnes on a beaucoup concentré nos
travaux dans un premier temps sur les
questions de gaz à effet de serre et de
gestion de ressources notamment de dos
donc là je reviens pas ce que c'est pas
le sujet d'aujourd'hui mais ça a été un
travail important en général au cours
des premiers mois de l'année de
travailler sur ce qu'on était les
annonces du président sur la question de
la gestion de l'eau et en matière de gaz
à effet de serre et je vous transmettrai
aussi le document qui avait donc comme
ça vous aurez la source l'origine sur
les différents chiffres qu'on puisse
être évoqués mais le travail qui a été
fait qui est en cours là et de dire nous
avons un engagement européen et français
de baisser nos émissions de gaz à effet
de serre de moins de 55 % en net donc
net des puis de carbone à l'horizon 2030
qu'est-ce que cela veut dire pour la
France concrètement et comment
en termes d'action concrète de levier
concret quelles sont ses leviers à
mobiliser pour pouvoir sécuriser
l'atteinte de cet objectif
par rapport à la situation actuelle nous
avons émis l'année dernière 408 millions
de tonnes de CO2 par an
baisser du coup les moins de les -55%
net c'est moins 50% en émission brute et
c'est accroître aussi le Puy de carbone
nos forêts nos sols etc pour atteindre
ensuite le moins 55 en net donc on a un
effort important à faire de belles
émissions de gaz à effet de serre vous
avez cité le site de 290 millions de
tonnes lui il accumule à la fois les
baisses d'émissions et les augmentations
du puits de carbone et donc chaque
secteur et ça vous le verrez dans le
document que je vous retransmettrez la
marche à franchir entre les émissions
actuelles et puis ce que doivent être
les émissions en 2030 elle est
extrêmement importante importante dans
tous les secteurs donc pour avoir une
politique qui est cohérente et c'est ça
le rôle du secrétariat général c'est de
mettre en cohérence qui est prévu dans
chacun des secteurs vérifiez que les
actions engagées elles sont entre
guillemets à la hauteur c'est-à-dire la
planète de d'atteindre ses objectifs de
de -50% des missions brutes en 2030 et
surtout de vérifier que nous sommes
cohérents dans ce que l'on dit dans les
différents secteurs et donc chacun fait
sa part et que en termes de de
bouclage physique alors je vais parler
par exemple de matériaux mais je parlais
aussi de quantité d'électricité
disponible de biomasse disponible de en
termes d'usage des sols etc que ce que
l'on dit dans chacun des des segments
est cohérents et qu'on s'en donne les
moyens donc
la politique de rénovation soviétique
est l'un des aspects moi dans mon équipe
j'ai pas une personne qui est dédiée
uniquement à cela puisque du coup les
personnes sont plutôt ont des casquettes
un petit peu plus larges et donc
l'articulation est notamment avec le
délégué interministériel de la nation
énergétique se fait assez naturellement
c'est à dire que nous on vérifie que
dans la répartition de l'effort de
chacun des secteurs la rénovation
énergétique fait bien sa part même titre
que les autres on regarde et notamment
les garants de l'ensemble des politiques
proposées en matière de rénovation on va
y revenir et natation performante en
termes de changement de vecteurs de
chauffage en termes elle est elle est
suffisante par rapport aux ambitions
qu'on se donne par contre on ne gère pas
opérationnellement j'irai le quotidien
de la coordination de toutes les équipes
ministérielles ça c'est vraiment le rôle
du délégué donc on vérifie que quelque
part la coordination de mise en place
par le délégué elle permet de faire la
part qui nous incombe en matière de
rénovation énergétique dans la baisse
globale des émissions que les moyens du
coup quels sont les moyens suffisants on
vérifie en termes de prospective je
dirais tous les ingrédients sont là ils
sont cohérents de façon à sécuriser
cette trajectoire là on peut répondre à
votre question sur sur l'articulation
ensuite donc c'est ça qui nous amène du
coup à définir aussi quelques ordres de
grandeur et chiffrage en termes de
baisse d'émission donc ça j'en reviens
du coup ce qui est notre objectif de
moins 50% quand on le répartit par
secteur en fait la marche est
extrêmement haute dans chacun de ces
secteurs là et effectivement quand on
fait quand on répartit l'effort on
aboutit en tout cas un objectif de se
dire il faut que les émissions baissent
au moins de de 60% dans le bâtiment et
donc ça c'est ça où on retrouve du coup
les 27 millions de tonnes de CO2 quand
je suis spécifique sur la question du
logement sachant quand on parle de
bâtiment on parle pour deux tiers de
logement et pour un tiers de tertiaire
et dans le tertiaire il y en a la moitié
qui est privée la moitié qui est
publique donc ce qu'on cherche à
l'effort en tout cas ça c'est important
aussi politiquement c'est un de
rénovation et de décarbonation des
bâtiments il doit avoir la même
intensité pour l'ensemble des secteurs
autant pour le tertiaire que pour le
logement il s'agirait pas de faire
porter au logement tous les forts de la
rénovation donc le tertiaire doit faire
sa part et elle est au moins égale mais
peut-être légèrement supérieur à ce que
ce qu'on demande à nos ménage et
l'intensité doit être élevée alors quand
on regarde après les leviers et ça c'est
aussi la suite de vos questions
on est alors la répartition qui a été
donnée est-ce que la fille que vous avez
mentionné là dans Libération elle
distingue mais un petit peu
artificiellement ce qui relève
strictement des chaudières fuel des
chaudières gaz de la rénovation en
réalité sur un logement donné notamment
quand on fait un changement de chaudière
on le fait pas seul et on l'accompagne
souvent de gestes de rénovation et donc
les choses sont plus compliquées à
démêler concrètement par contre ce qui
est assez clair en tout cas dans ce que
nous ce qu'on envisage de faire il y a
un effort important sur retirer le
vecteur fuel du chauffage et donc là on
a encore un assez grand nombre j'ai pour
y revenir de choisir fut à la fois dans
le terti et dans le logement donc il y a
eu sous le précédent gouvernement du
coup une interdiction d'installation des
nouvelles chaudières au fioul donc ça ça
conduit à un rythme d'être ici régulier
des chaudières après il conduit ce
rythme ce rythme uniquement au nom du
renouvellement conduit à garder encore
beaucoup de chaudières fuel en 2030 dans
le parc donc la question qu'on se pose
c'est comment on fait pour essayer
d'accélérer un peu ce mouvement là
lorsque l'objectif qu'on se vise c'est
de se dire il faudrait que 75% des
chaudières fuel actuellement en
fonctionnement puisse être supprimés
d'ici 2030 et c'est ça le sous-jacent du
chiffre qui avait été donné donc de 9
millions de tonnes de CO2 par an
réduites ensuite après le reste des
émissions c'est beaucoup le gaz le gaz
naturel et donc là il y a à la fois un
travail sur l'efficacité énergétique de
ces chaudières là pour les remplacer il
y a un travail aussi sur les
substitutions avec des alternatives à la
fois des pompes à chaleur mais aussi des
pompes à chaleur qui peut être hybrides
on peut garder un peu de gaz pour
pouvoir faire fonctionner ses pompes à
chaleur là ou alors de la bioénergie de
la biomasse soit du biogaz ou du bois de
chauffage pour pouvoir les remplacer
donc là le constat que l'on fait c'est
que si on veut être à la hauteur de des
ambitions qu'on s'est fixées en matière
de baisse de gaz à effet de serre il
faut que l'on réduise la quantité de gaz
naturel consommé dans le chauffage donc
ça c'est et donc c'est ça l'ordre de
grandeur de millions de tonnes de CO2
qu'on a qu'on a estimé et puis après il
y a un travail du coup qui est
indispensable sur la rénovation on peut
pas se permettre uniquement de changer
les vecteurs de chauffage pourquoi on
veut pas se le permettre uniquement
parce que d'un point strict point de vue
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre on
pourrait se dire c'est suffisant par
contre quand on fait le bouclage en
consommation d'énergie globale et qu'on
le met en regard de nos moyens fin de
notre énergie disponible parce qu'on
veut aussi gagner en souveraineté on
voit que on n'est pas en capacité de
pouvoir satisfaire tous les besoins si
on n'a pas par ailleurs une un effort
important en matière de rénovation
énergétique et donc aujourd'hui on a des
rénovations qui sont je dirais
majoritairement de changement de
chauffage et de geste simple et
minoritairement de rénovation
performante et donc là notre philosophie
est de dire il faut augmenter
significativement la part des
rénovations performantes on pourra
revenir sur les leviers pour pouvoir y
parvenir
un geste de changement de chaudière
seul si c'est dans une passoire il doit
pas être possible il doit accompagné
systématiquement d'une rénovation par
contre on pense pour l'efficacité pour
vis-à-vis du rythme à la rénovation
lourde c'est un rythme de mise en place
qui sera qui doit significativement
augmenter mais qui va pas tout d'un coup
concerner l'intégralité du parc de
logement du jour au lendemain parce que
c'est des travaux très significatifs et
donc pour pouvoir atteindre notre
objectif 2030 on se dit qu'il est
important pour les logements qui sont
d'ores et déjà raisonnablement isolés
donc si je simplifie les étiquettes AAD
on peut se permettre du coup de changer
plus vite uniquement le chauffage sans
faire la rénovation performante et donc
en cumulant un premier plan d'action qui
est de dire sur les logements qui sont
AAD changer les chauffages rapidement
plus de la rénovation qui est la plus
performante possible sur le reste c'est
comme ça qu'on arrive à documenter le
enfin en tout cas à réorienter l'effort
de rénovation de nos logements et donc
ça propose derrière de faire évoluer un
certain nombre de dispositif donc
notamment de faire évoluer ma prime
rénov de faire évoluer de monter en
puissance sur les outils du type le prix
avance rénovation
le préavance mutation ça suppose aussi
d'avoir un accompagnement du coup
personnalisé notamment de concitoyens
donc là c'est l'accompagneur Renov sur
laquelle je pourrais revenir si vous le
souhaitez ça suppose aussi d'avoir une
filière
une filière qui fonctionne donc là on a
des enjeux de filière et c'est aussi des
choses qu'on regarde au petit de la
planification qui sont assez majeures il
y a des bonnes et des bonnes et
mauvaises nouvelles donc on a un besoin
du coup notamment de personnes formées
et puis de salariés qui est très
important c'est des métiers qui sont
d'ores et déjà en tension et donc là
pour arriver à tout faire à la fois pour
les logements mais aussi pour le
tertiaire il nous faudrait former 200000
personnes de plus et ça l'ordre de
grandeur et donc ça c'est un c'est un
vrai défi il y a par ailleurs du coup
une probablement une réorganisation un
nombre d'acteurs qui sont beaucoup très
présents uniquement sur le neuf et qui
doivent du coup progressivement basculer
un peu plus sur les activités de
rénovation la bonne nouvelle pour le
secteur c'est quand même que ça veut
dire globalement plus de chiffre
d'affaires pour le secteur demain en
termes de en termes de parce que
l'ampleur de la rénovation est très
importante et donc c'est plutôt une
perspective assez positive pour ce
secteur là même si les défis à relever
sont très nombreux voilà peut-être en
proposer rapide et puis après chez votre
disposition bien sûr pour compléter sur
les différents points
merci beaucoup déjà pour ce propos
introductif précis et je laisse la
parole à notre rapporteur
merci madame la Présidente merci
Monsieur le Secrétaire général pour
vos premières explications
moi je voulais peut-être oui revenir sur
ce que en fait ce que vous avez déjà un
petit peu dit mais c'est vrai que la
vraie question sur lequel on peut
en tout cas réfléchir et se poser c'est
sur l'aspect justement l'objectif de
réduction des émissions de carbone
qu'effectivement peut être un objectif
qu'on peut atteindre si on va dans
l'absolu et qu'on change l'ensemble des
chaudières par des pompes à chaleur et
enfin en gros qu'on passe en électrique
et qu'on estime que électrique est une
énergie non carbonée du coup
on y arrive quoi enfin
forcément l'obligation de faire autre
chose et sauf que ben on bute à d'autres
à d'autres objectifs effectivement sur
la rénovation la rénovation thermique
globale énergétique des bâtiments à la
fois en matière de confort de santé
enfin d'autres aspects et puis surtout
de réduction aussi et de sobriété
puisque c'est quand même un des éléments
notamment que le Président de la
République a annoncé quoi sur la
question de la sobriété quelle que soit
l'énergie en tout cas de diminuer nos
consommations et donc c'est vrai qu'on
se pose beaucoup de questions sur
comment atteindre cette trajectoire sans
justement avoir une dérive qui soit
justement
uniquement par un seul geste et
notamment le changement de chaudière
sachant que quand on change une
chaudière qu'elle soit fioul gaz ou
autre et qu'on a pas de réflexion
globale sur le sur le bâtiment et qu'on
travaille pas sur la rénovation c'est
vrai qu'on va avoir les mêmes puissances
de chaudière qui du coup seront total
décalage avec
[Musique]
ce qu'il faudrait si on si on isolait ce
bâtiment donc voilà moi je voulais
peut-être plus de précisions en fait sur
comment vous
voyez en tout cas le fait qu'on puisse
mener de front ces deux objectifs parce
que je pense que c'est vraiment ça qu'il
faut faire quoi en tout cas sur
travailler sur sur l'ensemble beaucoup
de des intervenants qu'on a pu
auditionner nous ont plutôt
dit que
des doutes en tout cas sur juste
l'intervention par un seul geste et de
dire qu'il faut vraiment se concentrer
sur une rénovation globale après la
question comment comment on le fait
comment comment on y arrive et c'est
vrai que ce soit le conseil pour climat
France énergie et ça sont vraiment sur
cette sur cette vision là donc je
voulais voir un petit peu soit vous quel
était votre
aspect c'est vrai que Julien Normandie à
l'inverse nous disait que il fallait
quand même garder la rénovation par
geste parce que c'était aussi une porte
d'entrée et que du coup le fait de faire
un geste pouvait amener à d'autres etc
moi ce qui me semble quand même c'est
que quel que soit le nombre de gestes
c'est qu'il faut qu'il y ait une étude
complète et qui ait une visibilité un
accompagnement en termes de
d'ingénierie sur sur ce qu'on doit faire
sur le bâtiment et sur les sur les
priorités mais du coup quel est voilà
votre vision sur cet aspect là j'avais
une autre question sur l'intégration et
est-ce que vous avez des réflexions sur
le confort d'été parce que c'est vrai
que c'est quelque chose qui a été
un peu mis de côté en tout cas sur la
réflexion sur la rénovation la
rénovation thermique des logements et
alors qu'on voit que c'est quelque chose
qui va devenir de plus en plus
problématique en tout cas sur le confort
dans les bâtiments mais qui va avoir
aussi une application énergétique parce
que ça veut dire que c'est une manière
si on règle problématique avec
des climatiseurs et de la climatisation
de la même manière on va augmenter notre
consommation énergétique alors même si
c'est de l'électrique voilà mais on
retombe dans les mêmes dans les mêmes
problématiques et c'est vrai qu'on voit
par exemple dans le DPE que cette aspect
là en tout cas de la du confort d'été
n'est pas n'est pas intégré
donc avoir aussi votre avis là dessus et
puis en lien
et c'est vrai que sur le confort d'été
on s'aperçoit que c'est plutôt vers les
matériaux biosourcés sur lequel à la
fois qui ont de l'inertie etc et qui
peuvent répondre justement à ce
problématiques de confort d'été et donc
aussi sur cette question là et vous en
avez un petit peu parlé sur les
questions de filière
la filière on va dire classique
effectivement là sur toute la formation
mais il y a aussi quelque chose que je
trouve plutôt intéressant et en lien
avec les territoires c'est des nouvelles
filières en tout cas sur la production
de matériaux matériaux bio sourcés et
puis derrière ben tout ce qui est
formation accompagnement des des
entreprises et des artisans pour mettre
en place ces nouveaux matériaux
une dernière question sur plusieurs des
intervenants aussi et ça va avec la
planification sur une loi de
programmation donc beaucoup nous
ont dit qu'il fallait aller vers une
boîte de programmation et que c'était
vraiment nécessaire d'avoir cette
visibilité de visibilité là donc avoir
votre votre avis sur cette sur cette
question et puis un dernier point sur
vous en avez parlé aussi sur le gaz et
les chaudières gaz c'est vrai que on
peut avoir effectivement ce réflexe de
dire on arrête le fioul on arrête le gaz
puisque ce sont des énergies carbonées
puis après il y a des il y a des
spécificités locales notamment avec la
méthanisation le fait qu'il y ait des
réseaux de gaz qui puisse exister et
donc qui puisse être intéressant et
c'est vrai qui est venu aussi du coup
l'idée notamment en termes d'aide et
d'orientation qui puisse être des
orientations et des aides du coup plus
ciblées en fonction des territoires quoi
c'est de dire en fonction des
spécificités des territoires et de la
production d'énergie de en fonction de
chaque de chaque territoire c'est vrai
que là par exemple on a des unités de
méthanisation qui a un réseau de gaz
un peu dommage du coup de ne pas
utiliser ce ce mode d'énergie donc on va
avoir un peu aussi votre vision par
rapport à ça merci
je reprends les différents points donc
le premier je vous confirme c'était
aussi ce que je vous disais en
introduction que on est clairement pas
sur une une stratégie qui serait
uniquement limitée au changement de
chaudière de façon à pouvoir atteindre
nos objectifs un comme vous l'avez dit
le sujet de la sobriété en comportement
déjà elle est importante comme le temps
la première étape et puis deux de toute
façon quand on tire le trait de ce que
voudrait dire du coup uniquement changer
les chaudières on voit bien que à la
fois en termes de quantité d'électricité
consommée en matière de biomasse parce
que c'est l'alternative ça peut être le
bois ou le biogaz du coup on n'a pas des
ressources suffisantes pour pouvoir
faire les choses correctement sur
l'électricité on pourra des sujets de
pointe qui pourrait apparaître etc donc
on a un impératif du coup qui est de
combiner rénovation et puis changement
de vecteur et ça je pense que ça fait
absolument en tout cas pour nous pas du
tout de débat
après ce que notre analyse aussi c'est
que même en poussant les curseurs au
maximum
c'est insuffisant pour pouvoir atteindre
l'ampleur de la baisse des missions de
gaz à effet de serre qui est nécessaire
à l'horizon 2030 d'où se complément
d'action du coup qui est de dire on
continue encore le geste de changer de
chaudière qui peut s'accompagner
d'ailleurs d'un ou deux gestes
complémentaires par contre on les cibles
sur les logements qui sont d'ores et
déjà les plus performants donc ce que je
vous dis tout à l'heure un logement qui
est étiquette ABCD du coup il peut
s'améliorer s'il essaoud parce que du
coup on peut faire mieux pour autant ça
n'est pas une passoire et c'est quand
même raisonnablement isolé à ce stade
tous ceux qui sont comme ça et qui se
chauffent 100% gaz naturel ou même au
fioul ça peut exister il y a pas
d'hésitation à avoir il faut maintenir
le geste de changement de chaudière pour
pouvoir gagner rapidement en baisse des
missions de gaz à effet de serre et donc
c'est le cumul de ces deux approches là
que l'on que l'on doit mettre en oeuvre
donc ça m'a prime rénov c'est un bon
outil pour ça parce qu'il permet de
financer les deux par contre ce qu'on
voit c'est que ma prime rénov c'est un
guichet ouvert donc ce qu'il faut c'est
faire de l'allée vers aller voir les
gens qui sont ceux qui sont dans les
passoires ceux qui sont dans ces
étiquettes du coup moi performantes pour
les engager dans cette dans ce dans ce
parcours de rénovation et en leur
proposant d'entrer de jeu ce qui est une
Réno performance et puis en essayant
ensuite dans les amener dans un parcours
de travaux donc c'est ça c'est ça la
stratégie qu'on essaye de déployer ça va
nous amener à proposer dans les
prochaines semaines de mois des
évolutions du coup notamment pour pour
pouvoir intensifier les rénovations
performantes
sur la partie sur la et donc derrière
aussi
sur la partie confort d'été je vous
rejoins tout à fait sur le fait de se
dire que c'est un élément important
notamment dans notre logique
d'adaptation au changement climatique
puisque on est on est face à des
températures plus significatives épisode
de sécheresse etc donc dans le 9 c'était
bien intégré dans la RER 20 et dans la
Réno on a bien aussi pour
objectif d'intégrer aussi ces éléments
de confort d'été dans dans les
diagnostics de des logements et donc
aussi dans les parcours de travaux et de
l'intégrer dans la notion de Réno de
rénaux performante aussi
sur la partie de la des filières et des
matériaux donc il y a donc je le disais
tout à l'heure donc un enjeux
structuration de filière qui est très
fort il y a un enjeu aussi effectivement
de développer le biosourcé ça je partage
totalement notamment des éléments aussi
de construction bois ça pose des
questions qui vont bien plus loin aussi
sur
quelle est notre quel est notre
ressource en biomasse comment est-ce
qu'on monte les filières amont qu'elle
soit agricoles pour un certain nombre de
produits chambre etc pour des isolants
ou qu'elles soient filières bois et donc
comment est-ce qu'on est-ce qu'on sort
notre bois français qu'on le fait dans
des séries qui sont sur notre territoire
et qu'on a l'intégration de la filière
aussi de façon à pouvoir
augmenter le taux de bois dans notre
construction donc ça c'est une réflexion
que l'on mène aussi qui est très liée à
l'autre chantier que celui de la forêt
notamment et sur lequel je pense que là
on a clairement des marges
d'amélioration puisque pour l'instant on
incorpore relativement peu de matériaux
bio sourcés dans le construction donc je
partage et l'importance du sujet parce
que c'est par ailleurs un moyen de faire
du stockage carbone depuis de carbone de
faire de mettre du bois dans nos
construction et le fait que on a des
améliorations à faire dans le secteur
sur la notion du coup tout ce qu'on se
dit là c'est les transformations qui
sont arrêtées très profondes à la fois
en termes de change de travaux chez les
gens de filières économiques qui
évoluent de monter en puissance donc la
notion de programmation et
l'indispensable elle est double j'irai
faire le même triple elle est donnée de
la visibilité sur ce que sont les
trajectoires physiques le nombre de
novation qu'est-ce qu'on cherche à
mobiliser pour que les acteurs puissent
s'organiser elle est financière puisque
derrière du coup il y a de
l'investissement à mettre qui est en
ordre de grandeur très élevé je parle
pas de nécessairement que
d'investissement public il y a beaucoup
d'investissements privés qui est
nécessaire du coup dans cette économie
là je pourrais revenir et puis cette
programmation elle est aussi en matière
de de matériaux et de filières
industrielle donc là on a parlé vous
avez parlé de matériaux bio sursés on
pourrait évoquer aussi le sujet des
filières industrielle par exemple de la
pompe à chaleur aujourd'hui on a des
acteurs en France du coup qui ont
construisent à qui les assemblent plus
précisément un certain nombre de
composants sont produits beaucoup en
Chine donc il y a un sujet aussi de
d'arriver à développer cette filière là
et donc on a à cœur dans cette
programmation de la montée en puissance
de donner des signaux à la fois de les
signaux clairs et en anticipation à ces
acteurs industriels qui produisent les
chaudières mais aussi de laisser le
temps nécessaire pour qu'ils puissent
monter en puissance et que l'effet de
notre politique au premier ordre ça soit
pas juste un afflux de chaudière qui
serait produite notamment dans des dans
des pays asiatiques donc c'est ça qui
est contraintes qui se qu'on cherche à
combiner pour avoir pour avoir cette
transition efficace
alors est-ce qu'il faut une loi de
programmation ou est-ce que quel est le
support et quel est le vecteur de cette
programmation je sais pas vous répondre
précisément sur quel est le bon vecteur
par contre ce qui est certain c'est
qu'il faut que cette programmation elle
soit expert qu'elle soit sur la table
qu'elle soit explicite qu'elle soit
discutée qu'elle soit partagée et après
il y a plusieurs façons de pouvoir
lacter en termes de support et de
vecteurs
sur la question du coup du gaz et du
fioul
donc je vous rejoins totalement sur le
fait de se dire que il y a beaucoup de
cas particuliers donc notamment quand on
a mis en place l'interdiction
d'installation de nouvelles chaudières
au fioul le texte prévoit que dans des
cas particuliers parce que on est dans
une zone du coup qui est non raccordé au
gaz et par ailleurs qui est en bout de
réseau électrique sur lequel on a des
problèmes de puissance et donc il y a
pas vraiment d'alternative et puisse y
avoir des dérogations qui soient très
ciblées pour tenir compte des cas
particuliers donc ça il faut qu'on
continue à cette approche très
pragmatique parce qu'il y a des cas
c'est possible dans 95% des cas il y a
quelques cas où ça reste difficile il
faut qu'on mette personne dans une dans
une impasse sur la question du coup du
gaz du biogaz etc j'assure un point qui
me semble important et là du coup je
dézoome un peu uniquement du logement
qui est que le biogaz notamment repose
du coup sur notre capacité à mobiliser
de la biomasse pour pouvoir le produire
et donc quand on fait le pied de colonne
qu'on additionne tous les besoins en bio
énergie qui sont dans industrie dans le
transport dans le chauffage pour pouvoir
décarboner massivement substituer les
énergies fossiles on voit qu'on a un
besoin si on veut le substituer en
grande partie par des BIOS énergie on a
un vrai sujet de disponibilité de cette
ressource
nous ce qu'on ne souhaite pas et ça
c'est aussi une des missions de la
planification c'est de remplacer une
dépendance qui est celle aux énergies
fossiles que l'on importe par une autre
par une autre dépendance qui serait
celle de la biomasse que l'on apporte
d'autres pays et donc il faut pas qu'on
ait un modèle qui reporte massivement
sur les importations de biomasse pour
produire les bios énergies donc ça nous
renvoie sur la capacité sur
l'organisation à la fois de notre
gestion forestière mais aussi notre nos
notaires agricoles mais aussi un certain
nombre de de récupération aussi de flux
de déchets de biomasse etc de façon à
pouvoir alimenter nos moyens de
production et ils sont pas uniquement
d'ailleurs la biomasse c'est pas
uniquement l'énergie c'est aussi la
construction c'est aussi l'alimentation
c'est aussi plein de choses et donc il
faut arriver à concilier dans un dans un
écosystème global
ou le choc du changement climatique les
hausse de température les sécheresses
plus fréquentes donc globalement réduire
les rendements de nos de production de
matière de matières agricoles et de nos
forêts je sais pas si vous avez en tête
mais il y a la forêt depuis 10 ans
pousse beaucoup moins vite qu'avant et
il y a une mortalité bien supérieure et
donc du coup mais l'ordre de grandeur
c'est on a deux fois moins de de
production de bois de nos forêts en 2000
en 2020 qu'on en avait en 2010 je parle
de la croissance naturelle des arbres
nettes de la mortalité et donc arriver
tout ce petit développement me conduis à
se dire c'est que il faut qu'on soit
très vigilant aux usages que l'on fait
de la biomasse et des bioénergie et
l'analyse qu'on en fait c'est que on n'a
pas suffisamment de biomasse produites
en France aujourd'hui pour satisfaire à
l'ensemble des usages et donc il va
falloir qu'on priorise un certain nombre
d'usages là où c'est pas substituable et
notamment un nombre d'enjeux industriels
sur lequel on ne sait pas substituer le
gaz sur lequel il faut privilégier le
biogaz il y a un certain nombre de
sujets en matière de territoires
insulaire ou de mobilité sur lequel il
faut qu'on soit vigilant et donc on ne
peut pas dire dès qu'on a du biogaz la
bonne solution c'est forcément de
l'injecter dans le réseau et puis de
l'utiliser pour le chauffage ou pour la
cuisson c'est probablement du coup il y
en aura et donc du coup une partie du
yoga sera destinée à ça par contre on
peut pas massivement du coup verdir le
réseau de gaz de cette façon là
voilà du coup quelques quelques éléments
de réponse
oui merci Madame la présente Monsieur le
Secrétaire Jean je souhaiterais avoir
votre avis sur le fait s'il n'y aurait
pas trop de normes de label à matière de
rénovation énergétique et qui pourrait
dire nuire à efficience des politiques
publiques dans ce domaine là
je pense qu'il y a effectivement alors
au niveau de label etc je n'a pas de
temps de label non plus que cela sur la
partie de construction alors je pense
qu'il y a il y a plusieurs sujets je
pense que en point de vue de
construction neuve les choses sont
extrêmement encadrées donc là il y a des
périodes les choses sont évoluées les
donc il y a un vrai sujet sur la mise en
œuvre de cette réglementation là et
notamment de pouvoir aussi dans une
période d'inflation sur les matériaux de
construction d'arriver à modérer du coup
le coût de la construction et c'est un
des sujets de préoccupation donc on
regarde ça avec attention après là ce
dont on se parle beaucoup c'est la
rénovation sur la rénovation du coup on
a quand même beaucoup moins de beaucoup
moins de normes et de la belges je pense
qu'au contraire on a besoin et c'est un
des problèmes qu'on a aujourd'hui dans
le secteur de la rénovation c'est que
moi en tant que particulier comment
est-ce que j'ai la garantie quand je
fais appel à des artisans du coup la
qualité des travaux sera là et donc du
coup la performance derrière en termes
d'efficacité énergétique sera suffisante
et je pense qu'il y a une partie de la
difficulté de la montée en puissance de
la rénovation est lié à cette
incertitudes là c'est à dire qu'il y a
des choses qui se passent très bien on a
un tissu d'artisan qui est très
performant très efficace etc et puis un
nombre de contreperformances importants
et c'est très difficile de s'y repérer
et puis on est en plus sur des sujets où
c'est difficile quand j'habite dans mon
logement dans mesurer immédiatement
l'efficacité et donc et donc ça il faut
qu'on arrive à s'améliorer je suis pas
sûr que ça passe par ça passe pas par
plus de normes ou plus de labels donc il
faut pas en rajouter du coup à ce qui
est là par contre ça ça passe
probablement par par du coup une
exigence de qualité un peu plus forte
sur les labels existants RGE par exemple
les noms de la façon dont on mesure la
qualité des travaux des artisans qui
sont labellisés RG la façon dont on
forme aussi notamment les 200 000
nouvelles personnes qui doivent arriver
dans le secteur pour atteindre des
objectifs et puis ça doit passer aussi
par probablement de faire un meilleur
lien entre la mesure de nos
consommations d'énergie dans nos
logements et puis les travaux ont pu
être effectués on a maintenant avec les
compteurs qui ont été déployés des
moyens de connaître un peu mieux que
cette performance là de faire un peu
mieux le lien entre les deux et ça ça
doit vous permettre du coup de d'arriver
à mieux mesurer l'efficacité des
opérations de travaux ça je pense que
c'est quelque chose c'est quelque chose
qui manque donc je pense pas que du coup
le secteur de la rénovation soit bloqué
par par trop de normes ou de label je le
distingue un peu du secteur du neuf qui
lui beaucoup plus encadré mais je pense
que du coup on a quand même pris
globalement un bon chemin maintenant les
acteurs sont plutôt à l'aise avec avec
les évolutions de la vague qui ont été
pas mal retravailler donc moi en tout
cas je je changerai pas maintenant aller
au stade où on en est par contre il faut
qu'on arrive à monter en qualité sur la
rénovation
question de Franck Montauger
[Musique]
j'aurais voulu savoir parce que je ne
l'ai pas trouvé sur le sur le site
internet du gouvernement
concernés j'aurais voulu savoir comment
s'organise le management de l'action au
niveau du secrétariat général sachant
que en propre vous n'avez la main
directement sur rien sur aucun secteur
vous dépanner en fait de l'ensemble des
ministères qui décline cette politique
générale dans leur dans leur propre dans
leur propre domaine est-ce que est-ce
que vous avez donc par un jeu thématique
voire par chantier des objectifs
planifiés dans le temps
si oui peut-on y avoir accès parce que
ça ça voilà ça permettra d'y voir d'y
voir plus clair sur sur l'avancée en
même temps l'efficacité des politiques
publiques qui sont menées dans les
différents dans les différents secteurs
donc ça c'est ma question globale
générale et
de manière complémentaire
il y a un domaine qui touche en
particulier à la rénovation énergétique
de la de l'habitat des logements c'est
celui de l'accès à la à la finance au
moyen financier
vous l'avez identifié comme un des
secteurs devant être travaillés j'ai lu
que c'était un cours peut-être que
depuis les choses ont avancé ou en
êtes-vous sur ce point en particulier
comme sur le point qui est indiqué aussi
qui concerne les sols alors c'est un peu
en marge de la commission d'enquête les
sols ça concerne ça peut concerner ou
avoir des évidemment des rapports avec
avec la on pense aux ânes des
choses comme ça on pense aussi à
l'agriculture voilà si vous pouvez nous
dire aussi quelques mots là-dessus ça
m'intéresserait merci
alors quelques éléments de réponse donc
ce cas là général il est placé aux côtés
de la première ministre donc du coup et
moi j'ai une double casquette à la fois
général et puis aussi au cabinet de la
Première ministre donc le on a un rôle
d'ensemble liés et d'Aiguillon
c'est-à-dire que on cherche on fait pas
la place des ministères sur les
politiques publiques par contre on
s'assure on est chargé de s'assurer que
ce qui a été mis sur la table en terme
de levier concret d'action est suffisant
pour atteindre nos objectifs et
suffisamment crédible on a un gros
travail de se dire est-ce que l'objectif
qu'on se fixe les étapes à ne pas
ramener est-ce qu'elles sont réalistes
ou est-ce que ou pas et comment est-ce
qu'on met aussi en cohérence l'ensemble
des différents sujets
on voit par exemple contre que les
équipes qui pouvaient être en charge du
coup de préparer la stratégie nationale
ma carbone avait parfois des hypothèses
qui étaient des paramètres qui étaient
très optimistes par exemple en matière
de déplacement alors que la direction
qui était en charge de ces déplacements
elle-même avait pas du tout les mêmes
hyp dans ce qu'elle travaillait en
termes de politiques publiques et donc
du coup il y avait des incohérences
là-dessus et donc notre rôle c'est de
remettre ça je dirais droit entre
guillemets et cohérent donc à la action
de la crédibilité et la cohérence de
notre action et puis il y a s'assurer
que quand on met tout bout à bout
ça rentre dans les limites physiques et
donc est-ce qu'on a suffisamment
d'électricité est-ce qu'on a
suffisamment de biomasse et puis ça veut
dire quoi en terme de financement global
et puis en termes d'emploi de
compétences de formation etc donc on est
on a on est les agrégateurs quelque part
de cette matière qui est travaillée par
les ministères donc on se subitue
absolument pas à eux mais pour vérifier
que ça boucle concrètement à la fin donc
c'est ça notre quelque part notre mode
d'action et on utilise donc là on a à la
fois les les outils classiques de
gestion de gestion de
l'interministérielle donc des réunions
donc la combinaison du sgpe et puis du
cabinet fait qu'on a à la fois des
réunions avec les services d'un côté
puis ensuite avec les cabinets et puis
autour de la première ministre un nombre
de réunions qui communissent les
ministres concernées pour pouvoir aussi
politiquement pas décidé des différentes
orientations et qui vont donner lieu
notamment à ça c'est ce qui avait
annoncé le plan de la République au mois
de juin de mettre sur la table aussi le
résultat de ces travaux là de façon à
donner à voir du coup à ce que sont
concrètement nos leviers d'action pour
atteindre notre trajectoire de baisse de
50 % du FSR en 2030 merci nous je
comprends la réponse que vous faites
c'est je crois nous en tant que
législateur ce qui nous intéresse c'est
de savoir au regard des objectifs qui
sont posés
et ma question de celles sont-ils
clairement voilà rendu public etc ou
vous en êtes l'action finalement ce qui
nous intéresse c'est d'évaluer
efficacité de l'action publique menée
secteur par secteur domaine par domaine
et y compris également un rapport avec
le sujet de la Commission de l'enquête
est-ce que ces données là elles existent
quelque part elles sont portées à la
connaissance du du public est-ce qu'on
peut voilà ça me paraît pour nous en
tout cas en tant que législateur faire
notre travail voilà pendant le but de
critiquer
c'est pas ça le sujet mais c'est de
savoir où elle en est quoi voilà donc
c'est ça ma question très concrètement
voilà je suppose que vous faites des
revues de processus ça fait dans les
entreprises ça s'appelle ça que vous
avez un système de management qui vous
permet de mener l'action tel que vous
l'avez décrite voilà
de résultat et d'avancer de l'action on
peut avoir accès voilà les choses qui
a peut-être deux choses là-dessus donc
nous les travaux du coup on est un peu
récent les travaux qu'on a amené étaient
beaucoup plus sur comment on documente
les mesures nouvelles pour pouvoir faire
de la prospective plutôt sur par temps
de ce qu'est la situation aujourd'hui
pour arriver à le type 2030 donc on a un
certain nombre de documents de travail
qui existe qui sont le statut des
documents de travail donc du coup avec
aussi toutes les incertitudes qui sont
encore liées aux différentes options etc
que l'on peut prendre
et sur lequel je pourrais vous
transmettre un certain nombre d'éléments
qui sont pas pour l'instant public parce
que document de travail avec pas mal
d'hypothèses mais qu'on souhaite rendre
public et qu'on rendra public du coup je
pense courant du courant du mois de juin
on peut dans le cadre de la commission
d'enquête vous transmettre un certain
nombre de ces éléments là du coup qui
sont du coup avec le côté non public de
ces informations à ce stade là et par
contre ces éléments là il concerne
beaucoup plus
les
la façon du coup d'aller de la situation
entre 2023 et 2030 pour atteindre des
objectifs beaucoup plus que que la revue
et l'analyse du coup de l'historique et
donc de ce qui a été fait par le passé
donc on a vraiment concentré nos travaux
sur comment on fait évoluer les choses
c'est ça le cœur de ce que l'on met
et donc et donc oui il y a besoin aussi
de moyens financiers pour pouvoir si
j'en reviens du coup au sujet de la
rénovation pour pouvoir y arriver ces
moyens financiers ils sont alors il y a
plusieurs segments c'est à dire dans les
bâtiments je prends le tertiaire
tertiaire privé on considère du coup
c'est 100% de l'investissement privé qui
doit aller sur le tertiaire privé on a
le décret le décritaire cirque qui
existe ou qui fixe des obligations à
l'horizon 2030 notamment en termes de
baisse de la consommation et de
réduction de gaz à effet de serre et
donc là on n'a pas particulièrement
d'argent public mobilisé le tertiaire
public 50% du coût du tertiaire là on a
du coup on travaille beaucoup sur
comment l'État lui-même sur ses propres
bâtiments du coup fait cette rénovation
là et donc là ça veut dire une
trajectoire d'investissement ça bien
amplifier ce qui a été fait aussi ou
quoi dans les années dans le cadre du
plan de relance pour pouvoir rénover le
bâtiment de l'État on a aussi le
tertiaire tertiaire des collectivités
donc là dans la République s'est
exprimée sur la rénovation des écoles et
donc là alors c'est le 9 mai monsieur
BECHU va du coup mettre sur la table
aussi avec les collectivités un plan
d'accélération de la rénovation du bâti
scolaire qui mobilise pour partie
notamment la Caisse des dépôts et ses
financements pour pouvoir y arriver qui
mobilise aussi un accompagnement de
l'État et puis après sur la partie sur
la partie logement donc là on a on
combine du coup les outils un peu
classiques mais qui sont qui sont à
étang donc on a à la fois une notion
d'accompagnement des ménages avec ma
prime rénove en subvention donc avec du
coup un soutien plus important et donc
ça je pense qu'il faut dire le renforcer
sur les décils les plus bas versus pour
pour laisser personne dans la passe on a
un complément en C2E mais ça je vous
apprends rien et donc notre analyse
c'est qu'il y a une partie il faudra
probablement aller plus loin en
mobilisant plus de ces deux œufs parce
que c'est aussi une façon d'aider au
financement du dispositif et puis après
il y a tout le sujet du reste à charge
elle reste à charge du coup en considère
que là le prêt avance j'oublie toujours
si c'est mutations ou rénovation à la
fin la façon dont l'a appelé mais
concrètement l'outil financier qui fait
que on ne rembourse le capital comme on
de la session du bien de façon à pouvoir
faire les travaux plus facilement pour
l'instant il est trop limité dans son
ampleur parce qu'on l'a trop fortement
conditionné uniquement à quelques
décennies de population il faut qu'on
l'élargisse pour que il puisse se
déployer plus largement et ça c'est un
outil qui est intéressant et puis après
il y a un certain nombre de ménages qui
lui coupe peuvent supporter le reste à
charge notamment en la 200 sur ton
économie de facture qu'on peut être fait
et donc tout le sujet derrière moi ce
que j'observe c'est que notamment dans
les secteur financier on a une
conjonction que je trouve assez
intéressante entre des bandes qui sont
soumises à des obligations notamment
d'avoir des parts vertes dans leur bilan
qui sont de plus en plus importantes et
donc du coup qui se disent mais quels
sont les projets que je peux financer et
qui trouvent que dans la rénovation
peut-être un outil enfin un plus
intéressant d'investissement de leur
part verte elle se heurte pour l'instant
à des difficultés qui est que au titre
de la réglementation bancaire il faut
documenter extrêmement finement quels
sont été les réductions d'émissions et
or les banques du coup par les crédits
immobiliers ou les crédits travaux
n'arrivent pas à voir les informations
suffisamment précises de quels sont les
types de travaux qui ont été faits les
gains éviter etc et ont du mal à faire
le lien je suis un peu technique mais
entre du coup les les la réduction des
missions liées auprès qu'elles ont donné
pour pouvoir les mettre dans leur dans
leur part verte de leur réglementation
donc là si on arrive à déverrouiller
typiquement ce type là donc là ça se
joue beaucoup dans le type de données
qu'on arrive à agréger les compteurs etc
on a probablement un steak une
opportunité que les banques aillent
beaucoup plus massivement dans le
financement de des travaux de rénovation
par exemple là c'est assez intéressant
comme comme angle
et puis sur la question des sols que
vous évoquiez
alors j'ouvrirai pas totalement la
discussion du design ici aujourd'hui
donc non mais néanmoins on a un sujet en
fait on a un sujet construction neuf
qu'il y a l'occupation des sols je pense
que tout ce qui est rénovation plutôt
stricte point de vue occupation des sols
très intéressantes parce que du coup ça
permet de refaire la ville sur la ville
logement sur des zones qui sont déjà
artificialisées et donc on est on est en
faveur du développement massif de cela
après il y aura aussi il y a aussi de la
construction neuve et continuera la
circonstruction neuve qui du coup
artificialise la question c'est
notre conviction c'est que
les collectivités avaient d'ores et déjà
engagé une trajectoire de baisse
artificialisation des territoires et que
quand on regarde ça c'est l'exercice
honnêtement n'est pas au bout du truc
parce qu'il est pas facile à faire
l'ensemble des enjeux d'usage de sol
donc je regarde les sujets
de construction neuve de
réindustrialisation de développement du
photovoltaïque de l'extension de la
forêt des maintiens de la surface
agricole utile et qu'on met toutes ces
tous ces ingrédients là pour regarder si
ça rentre concrètement je pense que la
bonne nouvelle c'est que d'un point de
vue
des surfaces au global on pense que du
coup on arrive à concilier tout cela
après et c'est ça c'est la difficulté
tout ce qu'on observe aujourd'hui toute
la question c'est la bonne répartition
géographique et la gestion locale du
coup de ces enjeux là donc ça rentre
global quand on regarde les surfaces au
globales après c'est des questions qui
sont extrêmement complexes prix
territoire par territoire pour pouvoir
avoir les bonnes les bons ajustements et
c'est ça qu'on a donc là du coup c'est
pas c'est pas l'état centrale de gérer
cette chose là et donc c'est là où du
coup le rôle de le rôle des communes des
EPCI et puis absolument indispensable
pour pouvoir avancer sur ça voilà
quelques éléments de réponse
merci pour pour la réponse je reviens
quand même sur le sur le Lausanne et
c'est conséquences si ce n'est
potentielles certainement réel
dans ce sujet en rapport avec le
logement
un rapport avec l'habitat et le logement
il y a va se poser très vite très vite
la question de l'accompagnement
et collectivité des particuliers pour
faire de la de la réutilisation de
logement parfois parfois très très
ancien inoccupé depuis des lustres et
permettre donc
malgré ces contraintes de poursuivre
l'accueil de population etc c'est
particulièrement vrai dans le dans le
rural dans des coeurs de villages etc
est-ce que ça ça fait partie des sujets
que que vous regardez en tant
qu'agrégateur je sais pas si c'est le
mot qui convient des politiques
publiques menées par ailleurs
concrètement par les ministères
concernés voilà et ça fait le lien avec
la finance verte
que vous avez évoqué précédemment on
peut trouver un lien entre entre les
deux sujets voilà est-ce que c'est dans
le dans le SCOP de votre
clairement au point enfin on prend comme
point d'entrée le fait de se dire on
doit satisfaire à la demande de logement
ça veut dire aussi plus de logements
globalement un logement c'est pas
forcément une construction neuve mais ça
veut dire aussi ça veut dire
réaménagement de d'un certain nombre de
bâtiments de logements déjà existants ou
réduire la vacance dans un nombre de cas
ça veut dire on regarde on regarde cet
enjeu là globalement parce qu'il est
indispensable et donc on se dit le but
c'est de pouvoir satisfaire à ce besoin
de logement et donc pour ça on active on
regarde comment on peut activer
l'ensemble des leviers après une fois
que j'ai ça le raisonnement pour
l'instant qu'on a eu il est macro
national et en fait la réalité du sujet
elle en se regarde zone géographique
personne géographique notre sujet c'est
les problèmes de d'offres de logement en
zone tendue plus que le problème du
nombre de logements global en France et
donc c'est là où on rentre dans une
dimension territoriale qui est
importante et là où on doit coupler et
c'est pas ça qui est pas facile à faire
et là pour le coup c'est aussi c'est
essentiel beaucoup des choses qui sont
entre les compétences qui sont entre les
mains des collectivités locales c'est
qu'on a bien sûr un sujet de court terme
d'offre disponibles et puis on a un
sujet de long terme d'aménagement
d'urbanisme d'un stricte point de vue de
développement du territoire de de
revêtualiser des villes moyennes pour
pouvoir aussi avoir
des lieux de vie qui sont qui se
redensifient sur lequel on a dû
développement etc à un sens en terme
d'aménagement du territoire à un sens
pour pouvoir répondre à un certain
nombre de problématiques
environnementales que l'on a aussi en
matière de déplacement en matière de
qualité de vie etc par contre c'est
clairement pas quelque chose qui va se
faire non plus du jour au lendemain et
donc on est sur du temps long il faut
qu'on arrive à lancer d'ores et déjà à
ce sens action corps de vie etc ces
programmes là de façon à préparer ce
futur mais là je suis plus sur du post
2030 pour avoir des effets extrêmement
tangibles en volume
la planification en fait elle a
elle peut être antinomique en fait avec
la mise l'épreuve du terrain comment
est-ce que vous travaillez pour pouvoir
être au plus près des territoires et
essayer de proposer en fait dans les
perspectives macro
des choses qui soient réalistes et
qui puisse être vraiment mis en place
après pour continuer la discussion sur
le financement en fait les travaux de
rénovation on sait qu'ils sont sur une
durée d'amortissement qui en général est
plus longue que la moyenne générale du
turn-over de vente de logement donc il y
a effectivement ce que selon vous
parliez sur la valorisation verte mais
il y a aussi à l'image du BRS en fait
qui pourrait y avoir une question de
transmission aussi de la charge que ça
soit pour la copro ou même pour d'autres
sujets comment est-ce que on voit ça je
voulais me poser une question aussi sur
la question du réemploi
et de la déconstruction et donc qui pose
pour le coup des questions assez
différentielles et de certification et
il faudrait peut-être essayer de de
débloquer ça et une de mes marottes sont
sur les allées aussi
c'est voilà on a rien à peu en France il
y en a quand même 40 mais c'est des
structures qui qui sont extrêmement
performantes qui vont vers ce dont on
discute à chaque fois c'est une forme
d'objectivation des diagnostics quand
même très extrêmement important pour que
ce soit les particuliers ou les copros
comment est-ce qu'on fait le lien avec
les accompagnateurs rénov et ce qui
voilà ce qu'il veut comment est-ce qu'on
arrive à faire donc là on rentre dans le
pragmatique mais en même temps ça permet
aussi de répondre
à des enjeux importants notamment sur
l'objectivation
des solutions
alors sur le premier point
je le dis avec beaucoup d'humidité c'est
à dire que le travail de planification
qu'on a amené pour l'instant on a
cherché déjà à faire une première étape
qui n'est qu'une première étape qui est
dire remettre en cohérence toutes les
multiples briques dont on disposait pour
regarder arriver à améliorer la
crédibilité la cohérence d'ensemble et
avoir des trajectoires complètes pour
donner la vision globale et ce que ça
veut dire aussi ce que je vous ai dit en
matière de vos sources d'emploi de
financement etc ce premier travail là je
dirais il a il a deux énormes cavéates
le premier c'est que
je suis pas en train de dire c'est ça la
façon de faire et de la prescrire à tout
le monde parce que du coup la réalité
c'est que du coup ce qu'on essaye
d'identifier c'est il existe au moins un
chemin possible qui est cohérent et
ensuite il faut que chacun ait c'est pas
uniquement l'État qu'il met en oeuvre
s'il y a énormément de choses qui sont
de la compétence des entreprises des
collectivités des ménages etc donc il
est presque plus illustratif pour se
dire voilà comment on pourrait faire et
donc du coup il doit se nourrir d'un
deuxième temps qui est à la fois avec
les territoires et donc du coup on a
d'ores et déjà commencé on a plutôt
travaillé pour l'instant la question des
lieux locaux pour commencer à rentrer
dans ce sujet là mais du coup on est
chez quelque part au tout début de cette
phase cette phase 2 en termes au niveau
du secrétariat général en tout cas et en
étant très conscient que l'ensemble de
ces collectivités nous ont bien sûr pas
attendu pour commencer à travailler sur
le sujet donc la question c'est plutôt
et c'est comme ça qu'on prend le sujet
de nouer l'échange avec elle sur la base
des travaux qu'elles ont engagés du PC u
t du stradet etc pour se dire au regard
de ce que nous on voit comme étant les
leviers importants qui ont le poil plus
efficace en matière de base de gaz à
effet de serre est-ce que finalement ce
qui a été engagé sur le territoire un
est-ce que c'est aligné pas aligné donc
du coup est-ce que l'ampleur des efforts
à faire on considère qu'ils sont
suffisamment importants ou pas pour
qu'on nous cette discussion et on va
certainement arriver à la conclusion à
certains territoires que la vision
générale moyenne nationale et ben elle
doit être différenciée donc peut-être
que un territoire on aura un effort plus
important en matière de transport moins
important en matière de logements ou
vice-versa de façon à arriver au même
résultat et ça sera très bien ainsi donc
ce cette discussion là
gérer elle est encore largement devant
nous et donc c'est en ça que on en est
une première étape et le même type de
discussion est nécessaire aussi avec les
filières les filières industrielles les
filières économiques on a commencé à
l'avoir dans l'article que la loi que
vous aviez votée climat et résilience
dans son fameux article 300 il y a des
notions de fil de contrat industriels et
de filières industrielle donc ils ont
travaillé ils ont fait des propositions
on les a intégrés du coup dans les
travaux qu'on a menés on n'est pas
forcément d'accord sur tout mais voilà
donc c'est cette discussion avec les
filières et au-delà des filières sur
l'engagement individuel de chaque
entreprise pour contribuer cette filière
il est indispensable
sur votre question du
financement
alors moi je crois beaucoup du coup de
au dispositifs de prêt avance rénovation
prévention mutation là pour notamment
regarder les successions c'est à dire
que je suis je suis propriétaire de mon
logement peut-être que j'ai prévu de le
vendre au bout de 5 ou 6 ans je peux
quand même engager des travaux je ne
payerai que des intérêts pendant la
période où je vis dedans au moment de la
session du bien au moment où je où je
cède mon bien je rembourse le principal
et quelque part du coup c'est l'acheteur
qui reprend en achetant son bien
directement qui reprend l'intégralité
des travaux et on continue ainsi je
pense que ça c'est une façon de faire
qui est assez intéressante qui résout
pas forcément tout mais du coup qui
permet quand même de faciliter un
certain nombre de travaux et qu'il faut
absolument qu'on
copropriété c'est un peu différent c'est
pour ça aussi qu'il y a eu les
évolutions récentes mais que vous aviez
aussi qui a été dans la loi climat et
résilience qui est le fond travaux aussi
pour mutualiser
mise en place dans les copropriétés d'un
fond qui est abondé sur la place du plan
plus réelle de travaux qui est mis dans
la copro et puis qui est abondait
régulièrement pour pouvoir faciliter le
déclenchement des travaux et le vote des
travaux du coup en Alger l'appareil il y
a énormément de facteurs qui font qui ne
finit en production de travaux mais ça
c'est un point positif qui paierait
quand même d'améliorer les choses
sur les sujets
de réemploi et assurantial je vous avoue
que du coup là en matière du coup je en
fait on a un enjeu plus général du coup
des économies circulaires dans le
secteur du BTP et donc là moi je crois
beaucoup du coup elle est pas facile à
faire mais la mise en place de la
filière Reb qu'on a mise en place aussi
pour pouvoir avoir du Réage de matériaux
alors les passants ça nécessite des flux
ça change un peu le jeu d'acteur etc
mais je pense que on va dans le on va
dans le bon sens je vous avoue ne pas
être totalement au clair sur le sujet
assurantiel qui est lié mais je
regarderai ce point là et on pourra
échanger là-dessus
vous déconstruisez un bâtiment vous
démontez des fenêtres si vous le
réemployez pour un autre en fait en
termes de décennale quoi de garantie en
fait on n'a pas de à l'heure actuelle il
y a ça existe pas ou très peu quoi donc
il y a des freins
et puis après alors le dernier point qui
je l'ai pas du tout évoqué pour
l'instant et il est important et de se
dire quel est le quel est le tissu
d'accompagnateur concret pour pouvoir
accompagner nos ménages donc moi je dis
ça quand même deux choses trois choses
même il y a le tout le réseau des
guichets physiques qui sont présents sur
les territoires donc nous on pousse
beaucoup le développement du réseau
France rénov qui fusionnent du coup
toutes les entités qu'on avait avant
pour pouvoir le densifier pour pouvoir
donc l'objectif c'est que dans chaque
PCI on est un point de contact physique
globalement si je devais résumer les
choses et donc ça c'est un axe important
après un guichet comme ça n'a pas
nécessairement les toutes les
compétences pour un accompagnement
personnalisé de qualité parce qu'il faut
pouvoir faire le di diagnostics de style
technique la recommandation des travaux
etc par contre il faut que ce guichet
physique il puisse renvoyer vers les
accompagnateurs de qualité qu'ils ont
été certifiés qui permettent du coup
d'avoir un accompagnement ensuite
qualifié donc il faut qu'on arrive à
pousser les deux en même temps donc le
guichet physique il est quelque part il
est là tout enfin d'aiguillages et puis
il va renvoyer vers les différents
acteurs il faut qu'on monte en
compétence en volume parce que là on
vient tout juste d'ouvrir le guichet de
certification des accompagnateurs rénov
donc là ça va monter en puissance tout
au cours de l'année pour qu'au premier
janvier 24 on a un réseau suffisamment
dense qui puisse être vraiment très
opérationnel et puis il y a à côté aussi
les opérateurs de je trouve de tiers
financement et les structures qui
existent et qui sont intéressantes et
qui doivent continuer du coup à se
déployer ce que je trouve qu'ils ont
pour le coup le package qui est à la
fois qualité des travaux solutions de
financement etc qui est quand même
intéressant même si les volumes pour
l'instant qui sortent sont encore un peu
petits donc on peut pas uniquement
s'appuyer sur elle
[Musique]
Christine Lavarde
ma question sera en réaction parce que
j'ai pas pu entendre le début des propos
mais c'est en entendant parler
d'assurance que ça m'a fait penser à un
autre sujet un peu connexe mais là qui
concerne le secrétaire général de la
planification écologique puisque très
récemment le ministère a publié une
ordonnance sur le risque de retrait
gonflement des argiles donc ça touche
directement les maisons et au terme de
cette ordonnance on pourrait arriver à
avoir des fonds publics enfin du régime
4 nattes qui serait mis pour des
montants considérables sur des maisons
qui sont des passoires thermiques avec
une obligation d'utilisation par les
sinistrés de ces fonds pour réparer les
dommages alors même qui pourrait être
vraiment beaucoup plus judicieux pour
ces sinistrés de d'utiliser la somme
parce qu'on peut avoir atteindre jusqu'à
150 160 000 euros d'indemnité pour aller
se loger ailleurs ou carrément tout rasé
et reconstruire quelque chose qui soit
à la fois performant d'un point de vue
thermique et performant d'un point de
vue du retrait gonflement des argiles et
ça tel que le texte a été écrit c'est
pas possible donc comment est-ce que
vous arrivez à concilier cette chose qui
est un peu absurde aussi bien d'un point
de vue micro que d'un point de vue macro
alors effectivement le sujet donc
autrement retrait gonflement d'argile à
sortir de monce récemment alors moi en
tout cas mon analyse que j'en avais
c'est que les
l'indemnisation que l'on donne c'est
stabilisation des sols donc en gros
c'est des micropieux etc qu'on finance
de façon à pouvoir stabiliser le sol moi
j'ai pas de connaissance là mais je suis
preneur de cas concret là-dessus de
subventions qui serait parce que même
100000 euros c'est pas totalement simple
de se racheter totalement une maison
pour 100000 euros derrière et donc du
coup moi ma connaissance on avait à les
montants n'étaient pas suffisants en
termes d'indemnisation pour pouvoir
financer du coup totalement du
changement d'habitation était vraiment
sur la logique de comment je stabilise
le sol avec le truc est quand même
intéressant en terme de stabilisation
qui est que
micropieux ça permet infinie de
supprimer totalement le risque puisqu'on
a stabilisé le terrain et donc on a
aujourd'hui quasiment 10 millions de
logements qui sont potentiellement en
zone concernée par des retraits
gonflements d'argile et donc au fur et à
mesure de ces stabilisations les sort
totalement du risque et donc on résout
progressivement le un problème ça va la
mettre du temps parce que c'est un
traitement flux et donc tout ça va
mettre plusieurs années voilà mais par
contre
je reconnais bien volontiers que du coup
il y a pas forcément eu de liens qui a
été fait totalement entre le sujet
passoire et le super héro très
gonflement d'argile et que ça faut
probablement qu'on le regarde plus
attentivement après par contre ma
connaissance on n'avait pas des
subventions qui étaient de nature à
pouvoir faire l'opération totalement de
relancement mais je suis prêt à regarder
les cas s'il y en a quoi il y a un
rapport du Sénat qui vous donne présente
la chose et nous on avait recensé au
moins 7 ou 10 cas de d'indemnisation qui
était supérieure au coût moyen de
construction d'une maison pris sur les
données France récentes
[Musique]
est-ce qu'il y a d'autres questions de
la part de nos collègues monsieur le
rapporteur
écoutez merci beaucoup Monsieur le
Secrétaire général pour cette audition
on souhaite une bonne journée au revoir